[موسيقى]
تتصاعد حده المعارك في سوريا بين قوه
الجيش النظامي والجيش السوري الحر في اكثر
من منطقه في البلاد اهمها حلب
[موسيقى]
ودمشق
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ل نناقشه من زاويتين
رئيسيتين ما هي الاهميه الاستراتيجيه
للمناطق التي يتركز فيها القتال حاليا بين
الجيشين النظامي والحر وهل تنبئ التحركات
العسكريه للجانبين عن قدره اي طرف منهما
تحقيق الحسم على الطرف
[تصفيق]
الاخر اهلا بكم بعد شهور من الاشتباكات
بين الجيش السوري الحر والجيش النظامي في
مناطق متفرقه من البلاد صارت دمشق ومن
بعدها حلب ارض المعارك الحقيقيه ورغم
اهميه دمشق باعتبارها عاصمه البلاد الا ان
حلب لا تقل عنها اهميه حيث انها العاصمه
الاقتصاديه واهم مدن
الشمال ليسوا ممن قد يسميهم العسكريون
خسائر جانبيه بل انهم هم الهدف هدف قصف
المجنون تواصل القوات السوريه النظاميه
تنفيذه على مناطق عده من البلاد ادلب حمص
درعا دير الزور حماه وقبلها جميعا دمشق
وحلب فعلى المدينتين تركز العمليات
العسكريه لجيش الاسد في محاوله استرجاع
الاحياء التي وقعت في قبضه الثوار في
الايام او الساعات الاخيره وللحفاظ على
مكاسبه او توسيع دائرتها يخوض الجيش
معار اريه مع الجيش النظامي الذي استدعى
كل اساليب القتل الممكنه نيران طائرات
الهليكوبتر والرشاشات
والمدفعيه ومع م ل العاصمه من اهميه فيبدو
ان لحلب عاصمه البلاد الاقتصاديه وثانيه
اكبر مدنها اهميه خاصه ولعلها في فهم
النظام السوري ستكون المعركه الاهم
والاخطر اليس لاجل حلب حرك الاسد ارته
وقطاعاته العسكريه المدرعه من جبل الزاويه
الاستراتيجي في ادلب لا يزعم الجيش الحر
السيطره الكامله على احياء حلب او مدن
غيرها لكن جيش النظام ماض في القصف من
الارض والجو ولا يتوان عن توسيع استخدام
ذخائره واسلحته كافه فقد ادخل المعترك
طائراته ثابته الجناح الله
اكبر الله اكبر كما انه هنا في تلبيس في
حمص يلقي ما يقول خبراء عسكريون انه نوع
من القنابل الاختراق المحرمه دوليا ليست
سابقه ففي منتصف الشهر الحالي استخدم نظام
الاسد لاول مره قنابل عنقوديه في حماه على
قرى ريفها الغربي وسهل الغاب تتساقط الان
قذائف مدفعيه الفوديكا والطائرات المروحيه
فيما تبدو محاوله لجر هذه المنطقه الى
اقتتال طائفي لكنها محاوله قد تنم عن ياس
صاحبها او تخبطه وربما قرب
نهايته ولمناقشة
نائب قائد الجيش السوري الحر مرحبا بكم
جميعا تطورات عسكريه لافته في النسق في
النوعيه وايضا في التمدد الجغرافي
والخرائط خاصه منذ عمليه التفجير الكبرى
لمبنى الامن القومي السوري في دمشق
الاسبوع الماضي هذا المنحى
التصاعدي حضره العميد في المواجهه المسلحه
الى اي حد انتج وافرزات استراتيجيه على
الارض كيف يمكن الان قراءه المشهد من
زاويه الربح والخساره خاصه على محوري دمشق
وحلب واشدد هنا على حلب والاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لهذه المدينه يعني دعن اقول
لك حلب في الاساس هي الكتله السكانيه
الاكبر وهي المدينه الاكبر سكانيا وربما
حركه واقتصاد وصناعه على مستوى الدوله
وعندما هذه المدينه تقتطع وتقتطع بشيئين
سواء بالسيطره على عليها او حتى بان يتم
فيها القتال على مده طويله على غرار ما
يحدث حتى الان في حمص في جور الشياح
والخالد والبياضه والقرابيص وخلافها الان
يخرج من النظام ربما المركز الصناعي
والاقتصادي الكبير نقطه التقاء المواصلات
الرئيسيه في الشمال العمق الاستراتيجي
الذي كان يعتمد عليه النظام في قتاله مع
في مواجهه اسرائيل هذا اذا ما تصورنا ان
كان لديه نيه بمعنى ان لدينا المناطق
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه هي على هوامش
الجولان لكن لديه 320 م م حتى حلب كان
يستطيع ان يتراجع وان يناور وان ينقل قدر
من قواته الرئيسيه الى هناك لاستعاده او
لعمل هجوم مضاد كل هذه الامور ربما تخرج
منه الان في مدينه حلب ومدينه حلب يبدو ان
سيطره الثوار على الاجزاء الشرقيه منها
لدينا الحيدريه ولدينا ايضا ايض قاضي عسكر
ولدينا مساكن هنانو ولدينا ايضا الصخور
هذه احياء ثقيله واحياء كبيره ويبدو ان
الثوار او المعارضون المسلحون وجدوا او
وضعوا ربما خطوه كبيره كما هو واضح على
الشاشه ربما التي تعرض الان على خلفيه ما
نتحدث عنه هناك حاله من عدم الاتزان لدي
النظام وربما برز منه اليوم هذا الاستخدام
الكث
الذي ربما منذ اقل من ساعه يتحدث
الامريكيون عن ان الاستخدام الجوي هو
مساله تصل الى درجه الانحطاط ربما في
العمل العسكري وهذا يؤشر لمشاكل كبرى
ستاتي للنظام في القادم من الايام ولكن
هذه التحركات وهذه العمليات الحاصله في في
حلب هي بالنهايه متحركه وليست ثابته الى
حد الان اعتقد انها متحركه اذا نظرنا الى
المدينه ولكن لدينا على الارض مناطق امنه
اتسعت في الشمال تماما ووصلت الى ريف ح
حماء الشمالي لدينا مناطق مرشحه الان وكما
تحدثت هيلاري كلينتون امس على ان هذه
المناطق ستؤسس للمناطق الامنه التي قد
يفكر المجتمع الدولي او تحالف الرغ الرغبه
خارج مجلس الامن في ان يبدا في فرض حظر
جوي وربما درجه من التامين لمن يتواجدون
على الارض العقيد ملك الكردي على ايقاع
هذه الضربات القويه والمو والتي بدت انها
مدروسه وممنهج الى حد ما هل يجوز الحديث
عن استراتيجيه عسكريه بدات تتبلور بالنسبه
للجيش السوري الحر في هذه
المواجهه اخي الكريم احييك واحيي ضيوفك
الكرام طبعا الجيش السوري الحر
قد انتهج منهجا محددا
للعمل من اجل اضعاف النظام ومن ثم
اسقاطه بدات
العمليه بضربات خفيفه هنا وهناك تتركز على
الحواجز ومن ثم تتطورت الى ضرب
الوحدات العسكريه
المتقدمه من اجل ضرب الجيش السوري الحر
وتحولت الان الى المدن ومن ثم المدن
الرئيسيه الا وهي وحلب المدينتان
الرئيسيتان التي تؤثر على النظام بشكل
كبير حيث
العاصمه تتركز المراكز الاداريه
الوزارات الابنيه الحكوميه
وحلب المراكز المركز الاقتصادي والشريان
الحيوي الهام لسوريا بالتاكيد ان السيطره
على هاتين
المدينتين تمهد الى انهاء الص انهاء
النظام بشكل اساسي
يعني قوه النظام تشكل في تلك المدينتين
اكثر من
95% ولكن
ولكن عقيد كردي ما دقه القول بان تحركاتك
الى حد الان مازالت في خانه يعني رد الفعل
وليس الفعل بمعنى انكم مازلتم تفتقدون
ل للمبادره لم تفتك بعد زمام المبادره
الجيش السوري الحر بامكانياته المتواضعه
يعني ما
هو ما زال حتى هذه اللحظه لا يمتلك الا
الاسلحه الخفيفه التي لا تمكنه من
العمل
العسكري الممنهج في احتلال المدن هو يعتمد
حرب
العصابات يقوم
بعمليات محدوده في كر وفار يسيطر على على
حي ثم ينسحب منه ثم يعاود الاحتلال اي هذا
طبعا تتطلبه ظروف الموقف وظروف التسليح
الذي يعني امكانيات التسليح المتوافره
لديه زمام المبادره اعتقد ان الجيش السوري
الحر بات يمتلك زمام المبادره عندما اي
يفرض على النظام اي الحرب في اماكن محدده
عندما يفضها عليه في اصبح الاحيا الان في
قلب العاصمه دمشق س ساعود اليك عقيد مالك
في خلال هذه الحصه ابقى معنا السيد منظر
الزملكاني يعني كيف يمكن الان وفي هذه
المرحله بالذات الربط بين الحاصل العسكري
على الارض والسيناريوهات
السياسيه بمعنى هل تعتقد ان
ال الميداني سيكون في المرحله المقبله هو
القاطره للسياسي طبعا سيدي الكريم نحن
نعرف دائما اليد العليا هي هي التي يؤخذ
بها وهي التي يعترف بها نحن نعرف ان الى
الان النظام القائم في سوريا لم يتم السحم
يد القوى الدوليه منه لانه الى الان ما
زال او الى قبل قبل التفجير الاخير وقبل
سقوط الحدود يعني احن عندنا حدثين مهمين
جدا هي التفجير الامني سقوط كبار النظام
وايضا المعابر موضوع المعابر موضوع ليس
بالامر سهل موضوع له
اهميه فهنا يحاول يح من خلال اححب مركز عن
نقطه مهمه دمشق وحلب حاول النظام منذ منذ
بدايه الثوره الحفاظ على سلميه على على
على تحييد حلب ودمشق للابقاء شكل الدوله
اللي نحن عندنا في المشكله عندما نرجع
لتعريف الدولي بانها السلطه التي تحتك
استخدام القوه في البلد فال النظام ليس هو
الذي يستخدم ليس هو الوحيد بينما عننا
الجيش الحر عن الكتائب كتائب الثوار فلكن
يريد الحفاظ على شكل الدوله من خلال ابقاء
حلب صامته وم من خلال ابقاء دمشق سابته
لكن مع تغلغل الثوره في في دمشق وفي حلب
وبشكل كبير جدا وتوافق جدا مع مع مع الحدث
الكبير في التفجير الامني في في دمشق
وايضا سقوط المعابر ادى الى تهلهل الدوله
بشكل كبير والان انا اعتقد نحن نشهد عمليه
تنازع للدوله ما بين النظام القائم وما
بين ما بين الكتائب بمعنى الجيش السوري
الحر الشكل نن الشكل الشكل العسكري له لكن
هو عباره عن المدنيين او الثوار ونحن نذكر
ما اعتقد انه بشار الاسد نفسه قال اذا
كانوا يملكون الفضاء فنحن نملك الارض وهذا
الان هو يريد ان يحافظ على الارض لانه لا
سلطه السلطه السياسيه مرهونه بقدر بقدرتك
على على السيطره على الارض فعندما تذهب
السيطره على الارض ذهبت ذهبت السلطه
السياسيه تماما هي حتى هيلار كلينتون
وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه لم احت الى ذلك
في احد تصريحاتها الاخيره عندما قالت انه
يجب علينا ان نعمل او نتعاون عن كثب مع
المعارضه لانها تحقق مكاسب على الارض هل
معنى هذا ان الرهانات بدات تعقد على
العامل العسكري تماما الدول الكبرى لا
تؤمن الا بالقوه هم يعلمون في البدايات ان
النظام هو الاقوى وكانوا يراهنون على
النظام يمكن ان يقمع المظاهرات لكن عندما
انقلبت المعايير وانقلبت ميازين بفضل
الثوار اصبحت نحن ك نشوف دائما ال ترتفع
الو وتيره الخطابات السياسيه مع كل تحقيق
مع كل انتصار يحققه الثوار على الارض ونحن
نشهد الان تجاوب كبير من قبل القوى
الدوليه مع المعارضه كل ما يحقق الجي
السوري الحر او الكتائب الثوار على الارض
انتصار ميداني كل ما ترتفع لهجه ال
المجامله للمعارضه السياسيه اكثر فاكثر من
قبل القوى الدوليه فهذا دائما ميزان القوى
موجود دائما القوى الدوليه تتجه الى دعم
الاقوى او تاييد الاقوى عندما تنقد تنقل
مع حس كما كما ينقلب الميدان ا حضره
العميد الاحتكاك بدمشق العاصمه السياديه
العاصمه السياسيه في في اكثر من مره
وبعمليات نوعيه كبيره جدا هل سيحدث
المنعرج في في هذه المواجهه اعتقد انه
هيعكس في انه يجبر مراكز القرار على
الانضغاط الى داخل المركز السياسي للدوله
بينما ما يجري في الاطار الخارجي هو اخطر
الان هو ينقل الياته المدرعه ويغادر او
ويهجر جبل الزاويه ويتجه الى حلب ربما
لانه لا يملك ان ينقل قطاعات كبيره من حول
دمشق وانقلها الى معركه حلب الان ربما كما
نشاهد لدينا معارك في دمشق كما هي الصوره
واضحه برز والقابون في الشمال وصو الحجر
الاسود والتضامن في الجنوب ولدينا معارك
كانت تجري في بلده التل في شمال دمشق
العاصمه ربما بهذه الصوره التي تتواجد
عليها مركز صنع القرار مشغول بتامين ربما
المنطقه المحيطه به واصبح غير متفرغ تماما
لما يجري في الخارج ربما هذه تسمى عمليات
الخطوط الخارجيه وبالتالي علينا ان ندرك
ان ما يدور في دمشق هو في صالح حلب
بالدرجه الاولى يعني فضلا عن دمشق وحلب ك
حلبت رئيسيتين في هذه المواجهه برز معطى
المعابر الحدوديه وسيطره الجيش السوري
الحر على عدد منها خاصه مع العراق وتركيا
ما هي الحسابات الاستراتيجيه في وضع اليد
على هذه المعابر اعتقد ربما جانبين الجانب
الاول هو كما يعني قال الزميل معنا في
الاستوديو وهو فكره اهدار سياده الدوله لم
يعد لان قيمه الدوله وسيادتها هي قيمه
مرتبطه بالحدود بالدرجه الاولى ولدينا كما
هو واضح لدينا معبرين الان الجيش السوري
الحر يسيطر عليهم سواء معبر الوليد ابو
كمال او معبر الرابيه القامشلي او ربيع
القامشلي ولدينا مجموعه نشاهدها على
الحدود
التركيه السوريه لدينا معابر عده مثل معبر
عين العرب ومعبر جرابلس ومعبر السلام وهو
قرب من منطقه اعزاز ولدي ايضا معبر باب
الهواء هنا في هذه التجمعات ربما عندما
تنش تنشا المنطقه الامنه بمساحه كبيره
والحديث عنها بدا يقترب على انه واقع او
ديفاكتو سيف زون هنا وجود المعابر يعني ان
خطوط الامداد اصبحت مفتوحه ان من يسيطر
على المناطق الامنه يستطيع ان يتعامل مع
دول الجوار وان يؤمن للقطاع السكاني
والقطاع العسكري الذي يعمل من خلاله كل ما
يحتاجه من ضرورات اسمحكم الان في التوقف
اللحظات مع هذا الفاصل نعود بعد لمتابعه
[موسيقى]
نقاشنا اهلا بكم من جديد اتحول مجددا الى
ضيفي العقيد الكردي لاسال وانت
الفاعل العسكري على الارض اين يكمن الرهان
على هذا الثلاثي دمشق حلب والمعابر
الحدوديه في تصوركم وفي استراتيجيه
جيشكم
طبعا الجيش السوري الحر كما قلت هو يسعى
للسيطره على تلك المدينتين بشكل اساسي مع
توسيع دائره العمل العسكري على مختلف
انحاء القطر من اجل
توزيع جهد الجيش واضعافه في كافه المدن
وكذلك
التاثير من خلال الاستلاء على المعابر
الحدوديه حيث يعبر عن قوه هذا الجيش الحر
وسيطرته على الارض اعلاميا سياسيا معنويا
للجيش السوري الحر معنويا للشعب السوري
هذا اعطى في الحقيقه ققه قوه دفع كبيره
ل للثوره وعناصر الجيش السوري الحر من اجل
الاستمرار في الاعمال
القتاليه اضافه لما جرى في تفجير مكتب
الامن القومي والعمليه الشهيره يعني رغم
رغم ما سماه البعض مكاسب حققها الجيش
السوري الحر ولكن هل تعتقدون حقيقه في ان
تحسم هذه المعركه عسكريا وبشكل عسكري
خالص بالتاكيد
العمل
العسكري لوحده قد لا يحدث الحسم لا يحدث
الحسم لكن يحتاج
الى التزامن مع الحسم
السياسي نحن ندرك ان الحسم السياسي هو
مطلوب لكن القوه العسكر هي التي تدفع
بقوه الموقف السياسي للتاثير على النظام
وتثبيت المواقف الاكثر قوه امام هذا
النظام كما تعلم هذا النظام لديه ما زال
قوى سياسيه تسانده
اي يجب
ان تكون هناك قوه مواجهه القوه العسكريه
التي ينتهجها الجيش السور عقيد ملك الكردي
سيد منظر زم الكاني هل ترى ان هناك تنسيق
كافي الان في هذه المرحله الحساسه بين
المعارضه السياسيه في الخارج والجيش
السوري الحر وما هي محاذير الفراغ الذي
يمكن ان ينتج عن اي اختلال في في في هذه
العلاقه في الحقيقه هذه المصيبه الكبرى
التي يمكن ان تواجه سوريا فيما بعد سقوط
النظام نحن نريد ترابط وثيق جدا لما يح ما
بين المعارضه السياسيه وما
بين الكتائب كتائب الثوار او الجيش السوري
الحر يجب ان تكون المعارضه السياسيه
الممثل الحقيقي والوا
والفعلي العمل الثوري في في في في في
سوريا نحن نعلم ان الثوره لها جناحين جناح
الميداني والجناح السياسي يجب ان يكون
هناك تلازم ما بين هذين الجناحين اي تقسيم
من قبل اي جناح يحمل الجناح الاخر التكلفه
الاكبر ونحن نرى الميداني يعني سابق جدا ل
للمعارضه السياسيه فعلى المعارضه السياسيه
ان تلحق بال ب وان تمثله تمثيلا حقيقيا
والا فما فائده تلك الحوارات فما فائده
تلك الاجتماعات ل تحضرها المعارضه في
الخارج اذا لم يكن لها ذلك الوقع في
الداخل فاذا فل تعقد ما تشاء على سبيل
المثال من اتفاقيات ومن حوارات اذا لم يكن
لها تمثيل حقيقي ومن يطيع امرها على الارض
لا قيمه لكل تلك المبادر الى اي حد هنا
تعتقد انه حصل انقلاب ربما في في المعادله
وصارت هناك اسبقيه للميداني للعسكري على
السياسي طبعا العس منذ بدايه الثوره
العسكري متقدم على السياسي ونحن هذه
مشكلتنا في المعارضه السياسيه يجب ان تفهم
ان لم ان لم ان لم تواكب ان لم تواكب
العمل الميداني فسوف يضعون فعلا الس سوريا
في في ما بعد الثوره في في مشكله فراغ
سياسي ما تفضلت حكيت حضرتك لكن انا اعتقد
الاطراف الدو لن تسمح بذلك سوف تفض على
المعارض السياسيه معادلات محدده توافق ما
ما يؤول عليه الحال في سوريا ما يؤول عليه
الحال تقدم الجيش السوري الحر بالكتائب
الثوريه في في خصوصا مع قرب سقوط النظام
يعني اعتقد النظام الان نحن نعرف عندما
تسيطر على العاصمه سواء كان وعلى فكره
السيطره على العاصمه لي ليس ليس ليس فقط
في القوه نحن شفنا في تونس وفي مصر سيطر
بطريقه سلميه على العاصمه و واجبروا
اي الزعماء في ذلك الحين على التنحي فيمكن
هنا الاطباق على العاصمه واجبار واجب
بطريقه بطريقه بطريقه القوه الان نحن في
حاله السوريه واجبار بشار الاسد على
التنحي او هروبه او او اي سيناريو ثاني
لكن لن لا نريد احداث اي فراغ سياسي في
يؤدي الى انفلات الب لا نريد ان نخرج من
الدكتاتوريه الى الفوضى عم صفوت اخيرا كيف
تتوقع او ما المتوقع في قادم الايام في
طبيعه المواجهه بين الطرفين ما هي
السيناريوهات
المتاحه دعني اقول لك انه ربما سقوط حلب
يمثل نقطه كبيره وحتى اذا ان لم تسقط
فمجرد استمرار القتال فيها يعني انها
تعطلت تماما اقتصاديا وصناعيا وخرجت من
اطار سلطه النظام هل نحن في اتجاهنا الى
مناطق امنه ومنطقه حظر جوي وهنا نعيد
تجربه الجيب الكردستاني في عام 911 في
شمال عراق لكن في كل الامور المعادله الان
تنقلب المناطق الامنه تتزايد الاهم من هذا
انني اريد ان اذكر الجميع والجيش العربي
السوري الحر الذي هو احد مخدرات الامه
العربيه اذكره بكلمه تومي فرانكس كان
قالها للرئيس بوش قبل غزو العراق عندما
وجد ان جيشه سيقاتل دون قانون ولا قال له
جنود يرحبون ان يذهبوا الى قبورهم في كفن
من الصدق لكنهم يستشعرون الجحيم اذا ذهبوا
الى قبورهم في كفن من الكذب هذه هي
الرساله الى جنود الجيش العربي السوري
الذي عليهم ان يدركوا انهم عليهم ان
يتوقفوا عن قتل شعبهم وانه ربما عجله
التاريخ تتقدم من اجل ربما الحريه للشعب
السوري تماما غمرت منذ قليل بطرح السؤال
على
ضيفي من الجيش السوري الحر عن موضوع الحسم
العسكري هل تعتقد ان هذا ال هذا المصطلح
مازال مبكرا يعني ما زال من المبكر ربما
استعماله او حتى التلميح اليه دعني اقول
لك ان الحسم ياخذ اشكال كبيره المهمه ان
الموقف السياسي تدعم كثيرا بما يجري على
الارض والاهم اننا قد ننتظر انشقاق كبير
في الجيش السوري نحن جميعا ننتظر انشقاق
فرقه او تشكيل كبير من التشكيلات ربما
ينقل المعركه الى صوره لم نكن نتصورها نحن
امام حدث درامي كبير قادم مناطق امنيه
انشقاق لاحد التشكيلات الكبرى في الجيش
العربي السوري الحر المجهد المجهد ليس فقط
ماديا ولكن مجهد معنويا كما تحدثت معك ان
يستمر جيش في اعمال قتل لاكثر من عام
بصوره مستمره هذا ارهاق كبير على جنود
الجيش السوري العربي ونتوقع ان انشقاقات
كبرى قادمه ومناطق امنه كبرى وبها هذا
الامور ستسير ربما على مصارين متوازن
الدبلوماسي والضغط العسكري ايهما سيسبق
هذه هي ربما احداث الايام القادمه التي
ستاشر لها اشكرك جزيل الشكر صفط زيات
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اشكر ضيفي
هنا في الاستديو ايضا منذر زم الكاني
الباحث في مركز الدراسات السوريه بجماعه
سانت اندروز في بريطانيا ومن الحدود
التركيه كان معنا العقيد مالك الكردي نائب
قائد الجيش
السوري بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء